[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Orr's I prefer to think of a Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast with my
brother John and I answer your questions
give you dubious advice and bring you
all the week's news from both Mars and
AFC will dinner
hey John how you doing I'm doing well
I'm wondering if we can rename the
podcast or rebrand it a little bit to
make it instead of you just saying a
comedy podcast if we could just say what
it is which is a comedy podcast about
death uh
I don't know why we didn't just call it
that to begin with that not dear Hank
and John just yeah death comedy dot-com
no I like dear Hank and John : a comedy
podcast about death I'm a big fan of
title : subtitle I just I think that
it's a tried and true method but anyway
I am doing well happy new year I hope
that you're having a lovely new year in
Montana yeah we're back the dear Hank
and John was on hiatus and now we are
off hiatus you're not very good at
saying hiatus that's my review I think
you're pronouncing hiatus wrong that's
one of the most embarrassing things that
that you've ever said in your whole life
which is really saying something it's
been a good it's been a good 2016 so far
I've been sick for the entire time at
first I thought I was just hungover but
it turns out I think I'm ill because now
we're like five or six days into 2016 so
I think I'm just sick yeah a five or six
day hangover is definitely something to
be concerned about yeah I think it would
be unusual I did over overindulge on New
Year's Eve though it was a we had a
lovely time with friends but we do this
annual champagne taste test where we
have a blind champagne taste test we
taste like 20 different champagnes then
we try to rank the hahaha and all Dom
Perignon the nicest champagne this year
finished dead last dead last let me
guess nah in first yeah was was just
sprite mixed with vodka no that that's
actually there's a name for that
champagne it's called Andre and it
finished second to last just behind Dom
very young
the winner was Madame Liberty
an American sparkling wine so there you
go
can I read your short poem okay is it
about getting drunk
no it's about hope okay same thing this
is by Emily Dickinson hope is the thing
with feathers that perches in the soul
and sings the tune without the words and
never stops at all and sweetest and the
gale is heard and soar must be the storm
that could abash the little bird that
kept so many warm I've heard it in the
chillest land and on the strangest sea
yet never in extremity it asked a crumb
of me hope is the thing with feathers
just one of my all-time favorite poems
Hank Emily Dickinson that she just she
knew how to sheena how to write a word
she knew which words to pick I think
that's that's basically the whole the
whole thing of poetry that's I've heard
that that thing about hope being a thing
with feathers which I assume is either a
bird or a dinosaur I I don't think that
they knew that dinosaurs were feathered
in Emily Dickinson's day so I think it's
probably a bird but you know the author
is dead poems belong to their readers
you can read it how you wish what I love
about that poem though is that it talks
about the inexhaustibility of hope and
how hope never asks anything from you
and and is sort of always available I
mean Emily Dickinson at least in some of
her poetry seems to believe in this idea
of radical hope that's core to a lot of
religious traditions this idea that hope
is available to everyone at all times
even even to the Dead which is really
interesting to me so I just love this
poem it's one that I come back to over
and over again I first I want to say to
all of our science people out there yes
I know that birds are technically
dinosaurs and
that I just had to say that so that you
weren't gonna yell at me on Twitter
second I think that I think that hope
might be a Velociraptor hope available
to everyone even the dead hope is the
Velociraptor with feathers it doesn't
roll off the tongue quite as well but
it's still good it's still I do I like
it I don't think it's bad we are a
professional duo of people who answer
questions and and so that that yes we
get paid to do that on the Internet we
get paid through our patreon we get paid
literal hundreds of dollars a month
which goes entirely to the people who
headed the podcast and not to us but we
I still can call myself a professional
question ask answerer and also ask very
marginally which is a wonderful thing I
am basically this generations dear abby
nope and you are this generations you
know that etiquette woman who told
people like which fork to use well you
know dear Abby's sister was also an
advice columnist than a very famous one
named Ann Landers
they were sisters Dear Abby and Ann
Landers but they were they were they
were estranged from each other as I
recall they had no relationship so
clearly their advice was as dubious as
ours is anyway you are not the Dear Abby
of the internet nor I cannot believe
that Abby and Ann Landers are siblings
that blows my mind or were siblings well
they're still siblings they're just no
longer living siblings can we get kid
Weejuns the Velociraptor is available to
that can we please just move on to our
first question it's a good one okay Ari
asks Dear John and Hank if humanity
stopped producing food altogether and
started eating each other exclusively
how long would humanity last very
interestingly I don't know if Ari knows
this but this question was answered by
randall munroe who is also a
professional question answer and answer
er yeah and I will say a better one than
us yes ma you can go read that you could
read his answer to this question yeah on
his what-if column on the internet all
you have to do is Google I assume what
if humans only ate each other and then
if that doesn't work at an xkcd but
basically I remember reading that column
and it was it had to do with how you did
it yeah so the if you wanted to humanity
the existence of humans to last as long
as possible what you have to do is kill
off the vast majority of us right and
freeze us right and then over time feed
us to a small group like a sustainable
Lea sized small group of human sure
because as Randall calculates there are
around 500 trillion calories of human on
earth right now so that's a lot it's a
lot to sustain sustain us yeah yeah I I
I did a little bit of research into this
Hank I I only got as far as seeing that
the average human has eighty one
thousand five hundred calories worth of
edible food inside of it wow that is a
lot it is yeah well but on the other
hand you know I just I'd rather keep it
I'd rather keep it moving you know I'd
rather I what do you mean I don't know
whether or not eat a human or you'd
rather not be eaten or you'd rather not
have this this this hypothetical that
Ari has supposed to be reality which I
think everyone can agree no no when I
said I'd rather keep it moving I met
like on to the next question because I'm
getting destroyed I see what you're
saying
I'm getting disturb okay I understand
Anna asks dear Hank and John if you lit
a match on Saturn with the entire
atmosphere of the planet combust I know
that hydrogen is highly flammable and
that the atmosphere of Saturn is mostly
composed of hydrogen yes it would it
would combust and it would be awesome it
would be amazing it would be the
gigantic 'test ball of fire in the
history of the universe I've got a
couple of problems with how excited you
are about this first thank you for your
question is it you don't know it's our
welcome for the expert and I can't
believe you want to destroy Saturn well
I mean I don't want to destroy Saturn I
just but you know nothing can be created
or destroyed Hank I just want to turn it
into an awesome ball of fire
okay uh it actual answer to Anna's
question should I actually answer it or
you just want to move on again do you
just want to move on and not talk about
audio the things that I've no it's fine
actually actually answer we think of
hydrogen as super flammable because we
live on a planet that has lots of oxygen
in the atmosphere hydrogen gas is
actually fairly stable its molecular
hydrogen 200 and spawned into each other
and it's fairly stable which is why one
of the reasons why it is the most common
molecule in the universe but in the
presence of oxygen it can it would like
to violently exothermically react to
form water which is even an even more
stable way for oxygen and hydrogen to
beat to exist so water is super super
stable and awesome and so both of those
things would like if given the
opportunity would prefer to be I mean
I'm obviously personifying molecules
here but they would be in a lower energy
state if they were inside of water which
is why on earth hydrogen is flammable
but there is not a bunch of oxygen on
Saturn so you could drop a match on to
Saturn without destroying the planet
which is good news because if we ever
wanted to like send a probe there yeah
and the probe had fire coming out of the
back of it yeah we wouldn't want to
light the whole planet on fire that
would really interfere with our science
wouldn't we though I mean you would get
some science out of it you'd be like
okay well we've never been able to test
what what it would be like if there was
a giant ball of fire in space so now
we're gonna we're gonna look at one of
those right but then you know you
couldn't study any of them well actually
come to think of it I think there is a
giant ball of fire in space called the
Sun but the cool thing is that Saturn
and don't correct me if I'm wrong here
please Saturn would become our second
Sun and it would be like an on Tatooine
in star wars where there's two suns that
would be ah interestingly Jupiter is is
on its way I mean it's not on its way
but like if it were considerably more
massive than it is it it would have been
our second Sun it would have to be about
ten times bigger than it is but that's
not all that big
and we would have lived in a solar
system with more than one Sun if only if
only Jupiter were a little bit bigger
Hank do you remember when I said don't
correct me if I'm wrong I didn't correct
you I added information I ignored what
you said and then and then I talked
about how an interesting fact about our
universe and our solar system yeah okay
well I'm glad that we only have the one
Sun because earth seems to be a fairly
hospitable place despite all of the
carbon that we're throwing into it yes
yes it is a wonderful place to be I have
another question for you Hank it's from
Jackie she writes dear John and Hank why
do people get in serious relationships
and then quit talking to their friends I
have more married engaged friends than I
can count on both hands and only one who
still talks to me regularly I don't know
why you like to try and still hang out
with my single friends but I don't have
kids yeah well I think that when you
have kids everything changes because you
know you're sort of life and schedule
become focused around your kids and so
it's much easier to socialize with other
people with kids than it is to socialize
with single people who may have
different schedules but I have a theory
about this which is that we have like
made romantic love too much at the
center of how we understand the universe
as people and so when we get into a
romantic relationship we act like it's
you know the Sun and the moon and the
stars in the whole universe and the only
thing that we need and then it becomes
very destructive I suspect Jackie that
if you just hang around you'll find that
you're married and engaged friends begin
socializing more over the course of
their marriage I know I know that's true
for Sarah and me but like I've I'd been
I was in romantic relationships where
like I didn't socialize with anyone
outside of the relationship but that was
mostly because like the relationship was
like super super intense and you know it
was my whole life
which turns out I don't think to be that
sustainable of a strategy no yeah that
doesn't sound good
I will save
as a friend to people that the people I
have maintained friendships with are
often I should step back and say as a
bad friend
the people I have maintained friends
friendships with are often the people
who help me maintain that relationship
who are like hey do you want to come
over for dinner hey I'm gonna go see
this movie do you want to come hey I'm
moving this weekend I help me move like
people who actively engage it's you know
it's a thing that continues to like it
doesn't just happen on its own right
yeah I feel like it did when I was in
school it just happened on its own yeah
but now it's like you know if I want to
maintain a friendship with someone I
have to be like oh I haven't seen that
those people in a while I should be like
hey I'll make you guys dinner do you
want to come over I'm making macaroni
and cheese with Gruyere yeah you've got
to be a proactive in general outside of
school like in adulthood I found that
you have to be a very proactive friend
which is hard to do
well yeah it's work but it is yeah it's
kind of work but it's it's worth it but
yeah I yeah and I I do suggest I have
found that cheese is a very important
part of it yeah so whenever I go to
someone's house yeah or whenever they
come to my house there's always cheese
and I know that some people are lactose
intolerance and if you have lactose
intolerant friends and I suggest you to
find some alternate form of cheese that
isn't cheese like I don't know Pringles
Oh nuts
yeah Cool Ranch Doritos Oh gross no
[Laughter]
disgusting I gotta take a sip of
delicious diet cherry coke Zero in order
to get the just the idea of Cool Ranch
Doritos out of my head there's so many
chemicals in that oh wow I'm gonna have
to take a sip of just brain wash so that
I can forget how you just said there's
so many chemicals in that I love it when
people say there's so many chemicals in
that as if there aren't chemicals in
water as if water itself is not a
chemical I think I think your pride
think you like hearing people say that
just so you can see me Krynn
and want to tear out tiny parts of my
own brain oh gosh I hope that doesn't
actually happen we should move on to the
next question Hank okay I got one
this question comes from Avery who asks
dear Hank and John for my women in
literature class I'm reading Margaret
Atwood's The Handmaid's Tale great at
one point in the novel the main
character is talking about Hitler's
mistress and her refusal to call Hitler
a monster the main character thinks
about all the nice innocent even
endearing traits Hitler might have had
singing in the shower having a loyal dog
and he says how easy it is to invent a
humanity for anyone at all what an
available temptation my question to this
do you think that thinking of people in
a more complex way can negate their
negative actions or should we try to see
all people more deeply despite any
actions no matter how negative those
actions are that's a good question and a
big one is a lot of acid on maids tale
is about so maybe just read the rest of
the book is my dubious advice but no in
general I don't I don't I would say that
I don't think that people's lives get
worse when or or that the world gets
worse when we imagine people complexly
it may get worse when we project a
certain kind of humanity on to certain
people which is what Margaret Atwood's
talking about there but that's that's us
projecting our own expectations and our
own experience into others rather than
trying to trying to see them yeah yeah I
think that there's often this temptation
to to to try and understand these on
these understandable actions and so we
you know we find the easiest cognitive
way to understand them and that is not
necessarily related in any way to the
truth but I do I am not comfortable ever
when when we call other people monsters
because that that is clearly objectively
untrue other people are not monsters no
matter how how Despicable their actions
they are people and if we forget that
they are people then we we forget like
this sad truth of humanity which is that
humans do and have done terrible
terrible things to each other right I
think like it's we can't we can't
separate humanity from that
monstrousness not and not just because
of Hitler I mean there are there there
are other examples I mean Hitler is the
most common contemporary example and
certainly you know someone whose
individual life was you know
unprecedented Lee destructive to
humanity but but there are lots and lots
of examples of what what you know the
Romans called homo homini lupus yeah I
probably said that wrong but man man is
a wolf to man yeah and you know we'd
like to think of ourselves as somehow
fundamentally separate from other
animals or other predators but too often
we we aren't yes yes I picked this
question also because I've been thinking
about this in the sense of sort of sort
of like like a separate version of this
as I've been watching the 2016
presidential presidential election
happen and it is clear that strategists
on both sides are far more concerned
with getting the the person they see is
necessary into office than with telling
the truth and so there's just this great
like this huge amount of simplification
and vilification because like they see
like if we can get this person in office
that's what matters that we get a person
who will make the decisions necessary to
make the country better and into that
place but Eve like and and like I kind
of agree with that because there are
some truly terrifying candidates at the
same time if we continue doing this if
we continue escalating it the way we
have then we end up in a country where
everybody hates each other and that is
not like it doesn't matter who's the
leader of a country where no one can get
along because he's like it's like having
a place where people sort of agree that
the system works in that and that like
things are pretty much okay is the is
the most important
and I'm kind of like I understand like
this motivation and especially like if
you live and breathe it and never think
about anything else to do everything
within your power to get the person you
think is necessary elected but but my
impulse is to is to tell the clearest
truth and to say like you know like
things are complicated and and nobody is
quite sure what the best thing for the
economy is in one / one side wants to
try this and the other side wants to try
this and I know which one I'd prefer but
I'd like nobody knows for sure but then
you have a bunch of voters who are like
well I guess you're right I don't really
know so why should I vote I'm not an
expert on any of this stuff but you got
to get people to the polls so you create
this fear and that's what motivates
people to vote which is very frightening
well I don't think it's I don't think
fear is always what's motivated people
to vote and I don't think it's the only
motive No yeah I I completely agree with
you that like the quality of a political
discourse is is in many ways like more
important than who the actual
representatives are like if we had high
quality honest you know conversations
about about policy in public discourse
we would probably be better off
regardless of who was the president I
mean you know accepting outliers who
frankly the outliers wouldn't even be
candidates if we had serious political
discourse right I mean like not not to
single anyone out but Donald Trump would
not be a candidate for the President of
the United States if we had you know
high quality discourse about actual
policy you know we would we would
dismiss him as you know as somebody
who's built their career and their their
campaign around rhetoric rather than
around you know policy and governance
and I totally agree with you I I do
however think that we are not going to
change I don't see a way out of this but
I
I think that America's been like this a
bunch of times in the past and in the
long run it hasn't seemed to hurt us
that much like if you look at the
American economy since like 1910 it's
grown at pretty much the same rate
regardless of who was president
regardless of how you know deadlocked
Congress was the only thing that stopped
growing really is wages and and I don't
I don't see anybody fixing that so I
feel like the biggest problems we have
are problems that no president can fix
and I don't see any improvement
happening to our political discourse I'm
very pessimistic about it and as you
know Hank I try to generate the
optimistic but this is not a not a place
of optimism for me I also have had that
problem and I feel like I have that
problem more in election years than
other years where I just like I actually
don't I don't know that it's gonna like
I think it I think everybody things
gonna be okay I don't think that like
there's going to be an apocalypse unless
there's an apocalypse
unless seriously unless there's a solar
flare but that has nothing to do with
the political the political discourse I
think it would it would radically Hank
what a solar flare would radically
change the political discourse no one
would be like oh well I think that she
dyes her hair they would be like
somebody fixed the Internet I am cold
it's very cold in my house you know I
wouldn't be worried about the heat I
mean I can manage that I can buy wood
for a fire but somebody get me back
tumblr Oh we'd run out of wood real
quick John I don't know you haven't seen
my backyard oh it might not run out a
Warrior's but yes anyway I
I got a question from Jenny I feel like
we should move on okay it's just too
depressing John which Jenny was
intrigued by the conversation in the 1st
of December podcast about being able to
get to Mars if the earth was smaller she
says I am rubbish at science and enjoy
oh and enjoy you've given me small
amounts of easy to digest science
information please explain ok I'm happy
to do that thank you for your question
so if the earth were smaller it would be
easier to get to Mars because it would
be easier to escape Earth's atmosphere
it would take less energy ah for the
rocket this is right isn't it why why
you know that you know you're wrong
you're just messing with me ok let me
try again
if the earth were smaller it would have
less there would be less gravitational
force holding a rocket to the earth yes
aha and then that you would need less
energy to get out of the atmosphere huh
oh no don't just don't don't think about
me that's energy to jump like okay so if
the earth were smaller it would have
less gravitational force which means it
would be easier to jump like it would be
easier to dunk a basketball the way it's
like on the moon people can jump higher
than they can on earth and it would also
be easier to jump much higher if you had
a rocket boost than it is currently
so you could get to Mars using less fuel
and you wouldn't have this big problem
where the fuel is heavy so you need more
fuel to get the fuel to it to Mars so it
would be simpler so that's why yes you
basically answered the question exactly
how I I would have so great job all
right I mean it's all about jumping
you're just trying to jump my science is
so good Hank talk to me talk to me and I
want to ask you a question now okay now
that I've told you how good my science
is what do you think AFC Wimbledon's up
front starting strike partnership should
be
I think that it would be super good if
if they had an upfront starting strikes
partnership of see this is what what
hurts me this is me like egg sponsor oh
is this as far as a sponsorship question
all right I've got a question from
Rachel Hank it's a big one I want you to
who are you seated yeah that definitely
podcast sitting down I love to sit if
you had 24 hours to live what would you
do oh gosh do you do you bowling Wow the
whole time probably not probably not I
tell you what I probably wouldn't sleep
that's for sure I do love to sleep I
might sleep yeah I love to sleep I love
yeah I love a good nap I probably would
go to sleep at around 23 and a half
hours just so I wouldn't have to like
nothing I don't know it might be a
little hard to sleep if you knew you're
gonna die in a half hour you'd be like a
prehensile about this I'll tell you I
might spend a good hour of that writing
out some last words
it's nice to know the actual deadline so
that you can be like I'm not gonna mess
this up I'm not gonna get halfway
through this sentence I'm gonna say this
and I'm gonna not talk I mean I would
probably end up spending the whole 24
hours fretting about my last words and
then my actual last words would be like
Pancho Villa's who said don't let it end
like this tell them I said something
[Laughter]
gotta be prepared look I liked those
last words no they are pretty good
actually he pulled it out at the last
second you know the truth is if I had 24
hours to live I would probably spend a
lot of that time really sad with my
family yeah no definitely I think I
think the yeah I spend a good amount of
it as they say getting my affairs in
order
so just making sure that like I'd I'd
fixed up all the last will and testament
stuff and everybody knew what to do and
and talking to talk to people about how
to run VidCon and
maybe making a video I'd probably make a
video but then but then I would not make
a video oh I would definitely make a
video I'd yeah I mean Katherine would be
really mad at me about it but I would be
like I just got to make a last video and
I wouldn't edit it I dried film it and
I'd make you edit it
that's terrible I'd refuse well I don't
have time to edit a video I'm about to
die I would never I couldn't bring
myself to edit it I I think the idea I
would I would be furious with you if you
spent part of your last 24 hours filming
a video
I really would be I mean for me like my
professional life is super important to
me but if it came down to you know an
actual amount of time that was remaining
that was less than you know a month I
would focus entirely on on spending time
with my family so that I could in the
hopes that I could kind of like ease the
coming burden I guess but I don't know I
mean the great thing is that this is not
something that I you're in for I have to
say like I don't you don't yearn for
immediate death no no no I don't I don't
yearn for much foreknowledge of my death
like oh yeah no no not at all I'm one of
those people who would be very happy to
have it you know just to be tapped on
the back of the shoulder by death and
then turn around and then I assume
that's how it happens that's that's
that's third of the eternal question if
you if you could find out when you were
gonna die would you would you yeah
yeah I feel like I'd be like if it's
over 80 tell me but yeah but then I know
that it's some time before 80 if they
don't tell me right yeah that's kind of
terrible because then the whole time
you're like oh I know I know
yeah I would I see here's my what is
your over/under like if you were given a
number right now that you could live to
add that you'd take it the minimum
number that you would be like yes I
accept that I will not take my chances
with fate I will not take my chances
with fate I will I will take that no
that's a that is a great question
um probably like 86 what are you kidding
is that too is that too low no it is
completely unreasonably high no it's not
it's on the outside of the bell curve
you're gonna you would if you kick
weren't given 86 you're gonna take your
chances well who's doing that
who's doing the bet mastering I was
gonna say like 73 no way no way that's
on the inside of the bell curve yeah I
would take on the inside of the bell
curve to have a guaranteed life that
goes to 73 nope nope nope nope nope no I
would not
I really well yeah I got you got to play
the odds John you gotta say I on average
I'm gonna live that long anyway so I'm
basically like I'm not using this as an
opportunity to guarantee that I don't
die I'm using this opportunity to to
potentially extend my lifespan
oh yeah so I am definitely using it as
an opportunity to guarantee that I don't
die tomorrow like just the yeah we
definitely think about death differently
just the quality of life edition that
that I would have if I could be
guaranteed not to die tomorrow is
difficult to measure I can't believe
there's a 16 year divergence between our
over-unders on when we would accept a
given date day of death now I'm
rethinking it now I'm thinking maybe
okay my last might this is my final
offer
78 if I was given 78 right now I would
take it no questions asked hands down
because also that would mean assuming
that Sarah lives to be 78 or 76 which
she probably will because she has great
genes both j:e ans and GE and yes I
think that would allow us to celebrate
our 50th wedding anniversary oh yeah no
that's a good idea just to be like I
want to guarantee that I get to 50th
that's probably yeah that's that's a
smart it's a smart thing to do
yeah I take 78 there's my offer okay I
don't think about the the possibility
that I'm gonna die tomorrow like that
does not come up what is that like of me
in my brain and it is there it's
interesting to hear
it comes up in your brain it comes up in
my brain a lot I often get stuck into
obsessive thought spirals thinking that
I am in my my my final my final days of
life on Earth but I recognize that that
is a result of my you know like brain
brain disease yeah it does suck though I
remember calling you once I don't know
if you remember this I remember calling
you once I think during in 2007 during
Brotherhood 2.0 and and I was in an
airport and I said Hank do you ever like
sit in the airport and think about the
fact that all of these people are going
to be dead and not in like a very long
time either but like they'll all be dead
within a century and you were like not
really well which good for you like what
it's not a productive thought no like
it's not it's not a thought that I'm
grateful to have had or like it doesn't
like bring me into some wisdom that I
that I that I wouldn't otherwise have
access to I'm just like oh that's too
bad he's gonna die they're gonna die
she's gonna die they're gonna die poof
everybody listen to this podcast is
gonna die I that everybody listening to
this podcast that doesn't bother me
maybe there is one person listening to
this podcast who will be alive in a
hundred years maybe
yeah no you know I bet there's gonna
there's more than one really yeah I bet
there's I bet there's a I mean so first
we have to say that there's probably
people who are under the age of ten
watching the podcast listen to the
podcast which I think is the case yeah
the second we have to say that that in
the future lifespans will be you know in
a hundred years 100 years from now
lifespans will be a lot longer than they
are now so yeah I'm not convinced to say
that that there will not be a major
technological break like some kind of
apocalypse or the and that you know we
will continue to extend the human
lifespan and I I think that's a pretty
good bet so yeah so people under 10 if
you're alive in a hundred years
think about this moment think about this
and think about me and John and how
we're super super dead
but we had an effect on your life so we
mattered at least for as long as you're
still alive yeah you know Hank
ultimately that's why I love football so
much is that football is a thing that
survives it's a thing that crosses
generations and survives AHA it survives
the death of any individual and then
when you know the system itself tries to
destroy football by moving Wimbledon to
Milton Keynes football says no no there
will be football in Wimbledon in the
form of AFC Wimbledon the greatest
fourth tier soccer club in the history
of the world would you like to know the
news from AFC Wimbledon Hank well first
I want to say that it's really nice that
football gets to continue and and be
this eternal thing
unlike yeah the whole of human knowledge
which is which is embodied in the spirit
of exploration that that we have we have
imbued in our souls from the moment of
the of the creation of our the moment of
the existence of our species yeah and
you know and that that is a very much
more limited thing than this peculiar
institution of round things going into
rectangles on fields yeah yeah no I
completely agree with everything that
you just said especially the part where
you said that AFC Wimbledon was much
more interesting than Mars exploration
so you go so Hank we have missed many
AFC wimbledon games as a result of our
high 80s how do you say it again hiatus
hiatus as a result of our hiatus you
know things were looking a little dark
for Wimbledon you may recall we lost to
dag and red yeah that was never lose tag
and to Dagon red that's always a bad
sign and and there had been I think six
games without a win and then we lost a
Stevenage on December 12th and it was
really a darkness that we had a 2-2 draw
to Newport County well that were like
unimportant
say what'd you say I said Newport County
isn't fun to say we had dagen red and we
had skeeve an inch why aren't all the
yeah teams have great names Wimbledon is
also a pretty fun thing to say
wimba bagging bread tagging red Dagon
red lose to you I'd rather be dead do
they say that I don't know I don't I
don't know if they sing that song to
Dagon red I'll inquire so then things
started to turn around on December 19th
we were losing to Newport County we came
back we tied 2-2
then we had a standard Wimbley wombly
nil nil draw against Bristol Rovers and
then we've had two consecutive victories
on Boxing Day
oh no on December 28th AFC Wimbledon
beat Exeter City to nil and then AFC
Wimbledon beat Cambridge United for 2-1
including a goal Hank from our
montserrat II an international friend
Lyle Taylor I know it was very exciting
this means that AFC Wimbledon are now
10th 10th in league - I know I know it's
exciting you can kind of so Hank I know
that you're not a a big soccer fan but
if you are soccer fan you can kind of
feel whether things are going well or
poorly for your team based on whether
you find yourself looking down the table
or up the table you know are you looking
down and being like oh my god we're only
12 points away from relegation or are
you looking up and being like huh
we are only like four or five points
away from the playoffs right now AFC
Wimbledon are definitely looking up
because they are more than 20 well know
19 they're 19 points clear of relegation
Hank and they're only four points away
from a playoff spot
all right well all those teams that are
above AFC Wimbledon in the the table
yeah I wish you bad luck very bad luck
very very bad luck I'm starting to feel
Hank I'm starting to feel with the
decision about the new stadium that's
gonna be built I'm starting to dream
about dreaming about dreaming that's how
close I
- dreaming alright that's a beautiful
about AFC livin in Ligue 1 I feel as if
your soul is filled with velociraptors
job it's being lifted by these beautiful
flightless dinosaurs ah in Mars news
amazingly and and and somewhat
disturbingly
you your luck turned around on the 19th
as did Mars is from a great year whoa
from a great well it's around the 19th
anyway from a wonderful 2015 we got our
first really our first I think really
bad piece of Mars news that I will ever
I have discussed yet on this podcast the
Mars insight Lander which is which was
scheduled to to blast off in March and
land in on Mars in September and and use
a very sensitive seismometer to learn
things about the interior of Mars in its
geological history in it
why it doesn't have plate tectonics and
it clearly has active volcanoes but but
how how active is it internally what's
going on in there was they were doing
some tests as a preliminary test before
the launch and the this like this most
important instrument on the insight
Lander the the super-sensitive
seismometer had a leak in it it has to
maintain a vacuum inside of it so that
it for it to function correctly and it
had a leak and and that means that they
will not be able to hit this launch
window and as you know John Mars and
Earth both go around the Sun in
basically a circle and that they go
around a different rates and so
sometimes Mars is is like basically on
the other side of the Sun so vent like
farther away than this Sun really far
away and sometimes it's real close
sometimes is there like basically
next-door neighbors it depends on the
orbital cycles and and so the vast
majority of the time you cannot send
things to Mars it's just too far away so
the launch windows are very short and
they are few and far between which means
that insight will not launch until 2018
which is very sad wow that is a bummer
sorry yeah by the time it launches AFC
Wimbledon may be playing in their new
stadium yeah in Ligue 1
Wow
that's a that's that's a lot of jumps
John no it's just one jump we're
currently in Ligue 2 confusingly I don't
know I've that is the fourth tier of
English leagues our league one as you
would guess from the fact that it's
called League one is the third tier of
English football above that is the
championship which seems like it would
be the championship but no it's the
second tier of English football and
above that is the Premier League they I
mean could could they be any more
pretentious in their naming of leagues
this this this podcast is brought to you
by the pretension of the English Soccer
League people who decide things and of
course this podcast is also brought to
you by vacuums vacuums breaking and not
letting things go to Mars since 2016
podcast is brought to you by human
cannibalism human cannibalism the last
resort if there was no other food on the
planet but good thing there are 500
trillion calories of human blood that's
just so disturbing I can't let it go
and of course this and of course this
podcast is brought to you by gambling
with your life gambling with your life
sadly sadly you are not offered the
opportunity to do it by picking a number
at which you would accept death all
right John what do we learn today oh man
we've learned so much we learned that
every human being apparently contains 80
1,500 calories worth of food we learned
that John Green would like to drop a
match on to Saturn and see it light up
in a fiery fireball that destroys one of
the most beautiful sights we have to see
because he is a heartless evil person
and of course we learned that if Hank
green had one day to live he would make
a youtube video
just for posterity people would want
would get real good views oh man but you
wouldn't be there to enjoy the immense
wealth that comes from YouTube
advertising thank you for listening to
our podcast you can send us questions at
Hank and John at gmail.com or use the
hashtag dear Hank and John on Twitter
we're also on patreon patreon comm slash
dear Hank and John this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins team music is
from gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]